You know, I'm one of those people
that likes to finish something
as soon as I think of it.
If I think about something like
let's say picking out a flight.
I'll just take out my phone and
start picking dates.
And I found that I pretty often
encounter dropdown menus, usually for
things like dates.
This seems reasonable, right?
Okay, I want you to watch this counter
that just popped up on your screen.
It's going to count the number of taps
it takes for me to search for a flight.
Are you ready?
Watch.
Did you catch that?
Three taps to select a month.
Not a great start.
Here, let me finish.
[SOUND] Did you see how
many taps that took?
It's ridiculous.
Clearly, there must be a better
input than a dropdown.